I want there to be more conservatives
that are trying to participate in
Academia but I feel like the leading
thought or the leading speaking out
against it is basically saying it's a
waste of time it's completely lost so I
I think that the alternative to that is
that the you are seeing on the right a
growth of for example alternative
universities saying the worst thing no I
I I don't think so at all I think
competition is a great way of
incentivizing some change on on behalf
of universities that may have forgotten
that there's an entire another side of
the aisle in the United States no no
shot I don't believe even I don't think
even you think that so first of all
first of all let me make clear I think
the entire educational system at the
upper levels if you're not in stem is a
complete scam I think it's a complete
waste of money I think it's a complete
waste of time and I think that it's all
all it is is a formalized very expensive
sorting mechanism for people of IQ
that's all it is people take an SAT you
go to a good school you take four years
of I know I did at UCLA and
then we analyze based on your degree
where you should go to law school I
could have gone directly from high
school to law school with maybe one year
of training and then done one year of
law school and been done okay the
reality is that this is a giant scam and
this again it's a bipartisan problem but
it's just a generalized problem the we
we have and you want to talk about
things that hurt the lower classes in
the United States the bleeding of
degrees up is so wild and crazy there's
so many jobs in the United States that
should not require a college degree that
we now require a college degree to do
because there was this weird idea that
came over Americans where they mistook
correlation for causation they would say
oh look people who go to college are
making more money than people who don't
go to college therefore everyone should
go to college well maybe the reason is
because people who are going to college
were better qualified for particular
jobs because on average not all the time
but on average a lot of those people
were smarter and making more money
because of that and so all you've done
is youve now created these additional
layers of stratification so a person who
used to be able to get a job with a
college degree now has to have a postdoc
degree in order to go get that degree a
person who used to be able to just
graduate high school now it's the facto
you got to go to Juco and then you got
to go to college or nobody's even going
to look at your resume it's really
really terrible for people who can't
afford all of that it's led to this
massive increase in educational cost
that is inexplicable other than this
particular sort of bleed up and by the
way Federal subsidies for higher
education again one of my problems with
Federal subsidies for higher education
I'd love for everyone to be able to go
to college if qualified to do so and if
it is productive but one of the things I
did when I went to law school is I took
loans because a bank said I was going to
get my money back if I got a law degree
from Harvard but you know when you're
not going to get your money back if
you're a bank you're not going to lend
to some dude who wants to major in you
know art Theory because is that a good
bet there's no collateral right if I
give a loan for a house I can go
repossess the house how do I repossess
your garbage college degree from UCLA
there's no way to do that so you know
one one of my so yeah this is a broader
conversation about education in general
I think the educational system is
cruising for a bruising and I think all
that's necessary for it to completely
collapse on the non- stem side where you
actually learn things is for people who
employ to Simply say give me your SAT
score and I will hire you for an
apprenticeship directly out of high
school that it would cut out so much of
the middleman but as far as the general
point that you're making about
institutions I I may disagree on the
education and how far it's gone in
general I agree with you so it's a in in
general I agree and I get to use my my
favorite longest word in the English
language here I I would consider myself
in many cases an anti-is
establishmentarian nice right see I like
to drop that that's because if you're an
establishmentarian means you like
establishmentarian I'm an anti can you
say that word that's the one we all
learned growing up anti disestablishment
teris
long and then some K Group say what
about super Calif fragile and then what
about new M for microscopics or the
science terms or what about the 7,000
letter thing that's from part of uh
biocham I got my education the Soviet
Union so we just did math didn't Le any
of this that's why you're a useful
person Soviet Union math was that one
plus1 how to make that equal three we
know long words and he streams on the
internet and and I talk for so anyway
the but the the point is that I don't
disagree that there is a general
populist tendency on all sides of the
aisle to look at the institutions and
then throw them overboard I think that
some of that is earned by people who are
in positions of power at institutions
who have completely undermined the faith
in credability of those institutions I
think you have to examine institution by
institutions which ones are salvageable
and which ones are not so I'm not a a
full anti- disestablishmentarianism I'd
be partially in that camp there are
certain institutions like higher
education in the liberal arts that I
think we may be better off
without